welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Robert Shiller the Arthur M oaken
professor of economics kohls Foundation
and School of Management at yale
university professor Schiller has
written numerous articles and books
about financial markets behavioral
economics macroeconomics real estate
statistical methods and public attitudes
opinions and moral judgments regarding
markets he is the former vice president
of the American Economic Association and
former president of the eastern economic
association professor Schiller's column
economic view appears in the new york
times today we'll talk with him about
the squam lake report his latest book
collaboration with 14 of the world's
leading economist that offers a plan on
how to fix our financial system welcome
Professor Shiller nice to talk to you
today Marilyn let's begin with an
overview of the book tell us about it
well we convened all academic finance
financial economics theorists at a
remote retreat location in squam lake
New Hampshire in 2008 in order to think
about what we ought to be saying about
the financial crisis and what ought to
be done about it we are economists
theorists and I we thought we had a
unique perspective we worked for a
couple years to come out with a book
with recommendations about how they very
serious crisis ought to be dealt with
okay and how did the book come to be
written what's the story behind it well
I think particular credit goes to
professor Kenneth French at Dartmouth
College but this is really not a
Dartmouth College enterprise ken thought
that we should be a group of people and
not show any affiliation
at all in fact i had to pay my own way
to this conference as did all the others
it was a we wanted to emphasize that we
represented no political party no
institution at all it was just us
economists who are these economists that
worked with you on their report and are
there any commonalities that United and
motivated the group well the commonality
I think is that they are all scholars of
finance in fact we have eight of the
nine most recent presidents of the
American finance association in our
group so and we have a former chairman
of the Council of Economic Advisers and
a former governor of the Federal Reserve
System so there are people who are we've
had a lot of experience and with
different perspectives though and
different some of them are free market
economists some of them are more liberal
in their approach we have a little bit
of trouble agreeing and so not
everything that one might imagine could
be done about the crisis is in our
report but we sought common ground and
something that that we think represents
academic expertise and what were your
groups policy recommendations tell us
about some of them well the policy
recommendations are have a broad
spectrum and there's there's a lot of
them and so the dodd-frank bill which
came in was voted in and signed by the
president overlaps substantially with
our proposals but maybe our proposals
are a little different and and or at
least more refined and developed in some
dimensions and so I think they will
provide a a guide to people who have to
implement dodd-frank now in the future
so the proposals that we have in the
report are really based on
financial theory as updated and by
recent developments and they emphasize a
couple of principles of finance that we
want to draw out and explain one of them
is that the role of the government has
to be in intervening in financial
markets has to be defined in terms of
market failures as economic theory
describes them and a very important
market failure which we are concerned
about now is the systemic instability of
a whole economy so a lot of the
proposals deal with that we almost saw a
collapse of our financial system during
this crisis one bank failing leading to
another Bank failing etc another of our
principles is that the regulations that
we impose on the financial sector should
try to internalize the costs of the
correction of any systemic failure on to
the firm otherwise the incentives will
be wrong so we're very focused on
providing the right incentives for
people who are running financial firms
okay are there any challenges that may
hinder the implementation of some of the
recommendations well there are certainly
many challenge what comes to mind first
is just the complexity of implementation
the financial system is immensely
complex and it has a lot of hardwired
complexity that might have to you know
it's like changing a computer program
you have to you make one change and then
you discover it has all kinds of other
effects so it's difficult and I think
that's why the dodd-frank bill which
passed Congress is so frustratingly
vague it's not that the Congress people
who wrote the bill were inadequate it's
because no one can lay out a map for
renovating the financial system it from
scratch
all at once it's got to be a process of
learning and as we make changes
discovering what all the implications of
the changes are do you think the report
is having an impact well Barney Frank
who's the Frank of dodd-frank told me
personally that he has read the report
and he thinks that his bill pretty much
makes possible almost everything in the
report not that it not that it puts it
into law you have to understand the bill
has a lot of calls for studies and it
creates new agencies who would then have
the authority to do things but it
doesn't say that they will do those
things for example in our report we had
a recommendation for something that's
called a contingent capital this is a
technical term in finance and if you
look at the dodd-frank it calls for bill
it calls for a study of these and it has
given the authority to regulators to
impose them if they decide that it's a
good thing to do so dodd-frank I think
was wise in not imposing a new idea but
making it possible giving an authority
to implement this idea after further
study that sounds weak maybe but I don't
think its weak I think it's reality and
I think Congress was functioning well in
this with this bill will the group of
economist be meeting again do you think
we're already meeting again right it's
we're thinking ahead to yet more
proposals okay very good thank you so
much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your work my pleasure
Marilyn for more information about
Professor Shiller and his work please
visit our website at yale edu backslash
macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you